[Music]  25 years ago you played a concert in  front of the entire world  [Music]  one month ago you played in Barstow  California for 40 people most of whom  were there for $2 taco night billing Ted  what have you got to say for yourselves  be back to each other and party on dudes  you were supposed to unite the world and  save reality as we know it  we've spent our whole life trying to  write the song level reunite the world  why can't we just go to the future when  we have written it whoa take it from  ourselves  how's that stealing if we're stealing it  from ourselves  ah  [Applause]  [Music]  no way how'd you like our song it's a  little on the dark side but you know  that's cool  [Music]  you